Donna I was so looking forward to this
conversation because it is so rare to
have one a breakthrough artist in the
field of technology who has your
particular background and who has
decided to also become engaged
philanthropically what motivated you to
bring these two aspects of your life
together well I think it comes upon you
gradually I was not born into a wealthy
family I mean a solid middle-class
environment to be sure but not great
wealth but my parents were always very
generous and giving of their time and
their money and so I was I was raised in
an environment where it was important to
give back but you don't I don't think
you really understand the implications
of having great wealth until you know
you get kind of close to that point
yourself and as I did start to get into
that position myself over the years it
became clear more clear to me that I had
to start thinking about what the
implications were of that and I think
the number one implication for me was as
I thought about it that I had been able
to take advantage of so many things that
society had provided for me whether my
public school growing up or my parents
paying for my college or Yale and all of
it had to offer and that it was really
my responsibility now to do that for the
next generation and and I had to start
to kind of think about that and think
about how to go about that which is it's
not an easy thing to think about and how
you do that thoughtfully and responsibly
and with the most amount of impact and I
think I got I got kind of turned off of
the idea of inherited wealth I think
both from a perspective of society as
well as from the perspective of an
individual from a society perspective it
just seems to me it doesn't generate as
much creativity and innovation and from
an individual perspective I think it's
almost demotivational somebody doesn't
really have to work hard for for what
they're getting so you know I for
ourselves in my
family my husband and I we sort of said
okay we're going to take care of our
family we're going to make sure nobody's
out the cold or struggling or they're
safe they're safe but after that I think
the rest of what we've been able to earn
based on the privileges we've had in our
society we think we should be giving
back